so here's an interesting little story a
letter I received we did a story a
couple of weeks ago called what are
crazy reasons people have canceled
memberships and among some of the
different stories I told I mentioned a
guy who emailed me saying David I like
your show I like what you do I agree
with your politics but you are a
bachelor and I am a married man with
three kids and were about the same age
and I disagree conceptually with taking
money away from my family to fund your
bachelor lifestyle but great show love
the show will continue to watch and my
reaction was listen that's totally fine
I decide whether to support a worthy
causes financially based on the merits
not the marital status or family
situation of the other person or of my
situation but hate to each their own I
got a very very nice letter which I'm
gonna put up on the screen for you from
Christie and I'm not gonna mention
Christie's last name there's many many
Christie's doesn't matter this is just
someone who wrote to me who said David I
heard you talk about a person who wanted
to know how you could ask for money from
single moms to support your bachelor
lifestyle well I listened to you on the
radio every day I've been wanting to
become a member for months but I haven't
yet I am a single mom of three kids no
support from the father one child of
special needs and requires therapy and I
can't work a traditional job so I do
whatever small jobs I can and I'm
starting a business this fall but I
heard you say that this guy said this
and I became a member today I may have
to cancel at times and then come back
but that idea ticks me off because you
aren't trying to sell me something I
don't need to trick me into giving up my
money I need for my family so that you
can get rich I rely on your show and
other progressive shows like it to know
what's happening so I can plan how to
defend my kids from what's happening
around us just wanted you to know that
families like mine do value your show
thank you for everything that you do
what a nice letter from Christy and
there are many people you know there are
many many people in our audience who
make a lot of money and they don't
necessarily
barely support the show financially and
that's fine there are many people who
because of their financial position
understand the importance of the issues
we're talking about and the issues were
activating around and that's why they
support us and I could not thank Christy
enough what a nice letter and I
encourage you join Christy the support
the work we're doing it is a tough time
for the show
we've got patreon even just $1 a month
through patreon means a lot at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
membership is available david pakman.com
slash membership there's a coupon code I
voted 17 whatever works for you whatever
amount works for you don't think that
because you can't contribute much it's
not worth contributing at all because
through many small contributions we've
built the program that we've built